hey youtubers it's Charlie so ant-man is
going to premiere on July 17th so I
thought it'd be fun to do a hank pym
video just because the movies are making
some changes and a lot of people
confused because Hank Pimm's back story
in the comics is way different I'm gonna
have to explain a little bit from age of
Ultron so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen that movie yet in the
comics hank pym created Ultron in the
movies it's Tony Stark the reason why
the movies didn't go with the Hank Pym
back story is because Marvel wasn't
ready to do an ant-man movie but they
were ready to do Ultron so they were
just working with what they already had
that's why in the ant-man movie we're
going to meet an old version of Hank Pym
that'll be passing the torch to the
Scott Lang version of the character
there have been three people to use the
name ant-man
first was Hank Pym then Scott Lang and
then Erik O'Grady I'm not a huge fan of
the Erik O'Grady ant-man I think the
movie is just gonna deal with Hank Pym
and Scott Lang I don't think we're gonna
see Erik in the movie at all
but because the age hank pym up they're
also doing hope van died and his
daughter instead of Janet Van Dyne heard
her story in the comments is a little
bit different too but this is mostly a
Hank Pym video Hank Pym is most famous
in the comics for being ant-man and for
creating Ultron so let's just do like a
quick comic book history the character
debuted for the first time in tales to
astonish number 27 that was in 1962 but
he was only called Hank Pym it was until
a little while later in tales to
astonish number 35 that he started
calling himself ant-man when he first
started out he was just like a normal
biochemist married to a woman named
Maria trivia she was a foreign national
from Hungary living in the country when
they traveled to her homeland they were
captured by secret police they murdered
her and that became hate PIMs big call
to action the soviets became a big
antagonist in the comics for stanley
just you know just because we're in the
middle of the cold war this is the 1960s
because it was stanley that created the
character he had this typical heroic
call to action where he's like i'm gonna
write all the wrongs than justices the
world you know you can see stanley
shaking his fist speaking in stanley
voice eventually he discovered subatomic
particles that he started calling Pym
particles he used those to create two
different serums one for shrinking down
and one for getting bigger so he tried
it out and it ended up being a disaster
he got trapped in an anthill barely
escaped said Ethne and trashed his
prototype formula cut to a week later
he decides to try again but this time he
tries to communicate with the ants using
a cybernetic helm
he also made himself his first suit to
protect him whenever he shrunk down he
ended up getting captured by Soviets
they forced him to create a weaponized
gas but he escaped using his ant-man
gear and used the ants at a nearby
anthill to take the Soviets out they
were after in the comics you know he
went on to battle a laundry list of
villains as ant-man later in tales
number 44 Janet Van Dyne appeared for
the first time her father was Hank
Pimm's partner he got killed by an alien
Pym revealed the secret of ant-man to
Janet who wanted to avenge her father's
death he taught her to use the Pym
particles which at this point had been
turned into a gas and he used his
knowledge of biochemistry to give her
the ability to grow wings that will let
her fly so that's when she became the
wasp they fell in love and started
fighting crime as a team cut to like a
few issues after that entails number 49
he became giant man as you can imagine
that's when he started growing up really
big instead of shrinking down it was
just a refinement of his Pym particles
he turned them into pills that allowed
both him and Janet to grow really big he
found that it was way more effective for
fighting most crimes so he just started
growing big all the time instead of
shrinking down the problem is is that
whenever he grew past 12 feet tall he
would get proportionately weaker the
taller he got just because his body
couldn't support all the weight it's the
same deal when he shrinks down like he
gets proportionately stronger just like
they say in the movie trailer you know
you're like a bullet when you're small
really that was just a tool for Stanley
to keep the character from getting too
overpowered so a couple years after that
in Avengers number 28 he took the name
Goliath he got a new costume and they
changed the way his growing powers
worked because of prolonged exposure to
the Pym particles both Hank and Janet
were able to will themselves to grow but
Hank could only grow to 25 feet tall for
periods of 15 minutes at a time the
funny thing is is they had this incident
with the collector this guy here from
the guardians of the galaxy movie where
by hank derped stayed 25 feet tall for
too long and couldn't shrink down the
collector after the Avengers defeated
the collector to collector helped fix
them which i think is kind of funny we
just got done beating the crap out of
you so why don't you help me fix myself
so a couple years after that in Avengers
number 59 after the creation of Ultron
he took the name yellowjacket this is
the beginning of crazy hank pym Hamptons
always big kind of a crazy character
like a crazier nuttier version of Tony
Stark
eventually he creates Ultron Ultron goes
on to become one of the Avengers biggest
villains Pym gets in a lab accident
spilling a whole bunch of chemicals on
himself develops severe schizophrenia in
an alternate personality takes over his
mind this personality took the name
yellowjacket kidnap Janet Van Dyne
proposed marriage but because Janet knew
that it was really Hank
she just played along and they ended up
getting married in this big ceremony at
the Avengers mansion party got crashed
by a bunch of villains and and during
the battle Hank Pimm's real personality
reemerged because who cares of comics
don't make a lot of sense Hank and Janet
after the fact just decided to let the
marriage stand just a roll with it
because they were both in love they were
like okay why don't we just stay married
even though it was my alternate
personality that married you in the
first place yay for crazy Stan Lee's
stories so because hank pym had spent so
many years growing large like he'd
suffered so much physical trauma from
the effects of growing big he decided to
stop doing it and just continue to be
yellowjacket couple years after that he
became ant-man again for a brief period
then devoted himself to research and
passed the mantle to the Scott Lang
character that happened during Avengers
181 in March of 1979 but Scott Lang
didn't debut as ant-man in the comics
till that next month in April in Marvel
premiere number 47 that was the passing
of the torch in the comics the movie is
gonna do the exact same thing you know
with a slightly different way in the
context of the movie Hank Pym is an old
man who's built a really successful
company developed the Pym particle
technology but his partner Darrin
crossed the villain of the movie wants
to turn it into a weapon
he's kind of like the Obadiah Stane
character from the first Iron Man movie
Tony Stark is like I don't want to sell
weapons anymore oh but I stains like yes
we're gonna keep selling weapons it
makes us a lot of money so if you see a
lot of similarities in the amm movie to
the narrative of the Iron Man movie of
the first Iron Man movie don't be
surprised I know a lot of you were
bummed that we're not gonna see Hank Pym
as a man in the movie but supposedly
like there's a rumor that he will appear
in flashbacks in the ant-man costume
even though Hank Pym was yellowjacket in
the comics Darrin cross is going to be
yellowjacket in the movie so they're
just using yellowjacket is an outright
villain in the movie what I'm hope
is that hope Fantine Evangeline Lilly's
character somehow becomes the wasp using
the Yellow Jacket suit the idea is is
that if the movie isn't gonna do Janet
Van Dyne they can still do the wasp but
it'll be Evangeline Lilly she's one of
those actresses that can do drama but
she can also do action like if you saw
her as tauriel in the Hobbit trilogy
that just feels like a really easy move
for Marvel to make if they're trying to
develop stronger female characters in
the movies but if we were to see a hope
Fanta and wasp character she might not
show up till Avengers infinity war so
here's my big question for you you know
which version of the Hank Pym character
is your favorite like yellowjacket
ant-man giant-man kalaiy ahthe and do
you want to see Evangeline Lilly become
the wasp character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's actually a
good idea for my next bonus video maybe
I'll do a Janet Van Dyne wasp hope fan
time video just because her character
gets tied up with the creation of Ultron
Jocasta a lot of other big crazy
comic-book events be sure to subscribe
to get that don't be surprised if Marvel
puts a lot of like the Janet Van Dyne
comic-book character traits onto the
hope Van Dyne character in the movies
just in case you guys haven't seen it in
awhile you can click here for the
extended ant-man trailer and you can
click here for my top 5 craziest Scarlet
Witch and Vision stories in the comics
they're gonna be in Captain America
Civil War so I think Marvel's gonna have
some fun with that thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you